I am privileged and honored today to
talk to the amazing Amelia Jones who
plays Kinsey lock in lock and key Amelia
how are you today I'm really good thank
you I'm brilliant it's pretty cool
because it's actually I had to wish you
a happy belated 18th birthday thank you
yes that's amazing yeah I had a very
good birthday yeah it's amazing you're
talking to me the day after I add that's
being a trooper what I wanted to ask you
about in episode 3 when Kinsey used the
head key you see that she removes the
fear monster from her brain and it
transfers her to like Episode four we
see this different Kinsey that's more
confident and a lot of fear removed how
challenging was it for you as an actress
to kind of play that line to make it
like believable and not so over-the-top
and like what was that process like yeah
well it was so fun I think that's what
kind of Drew me to Kennedy initially
just the fact that it kind of explains
two characters rolled into one
before the loss of her father can be was
individualistic free-spirited creative
confident this was out there she dyed
her hair with her own styles he wasn't
afraid of something out but then after
her dad's murder she has borderline
anxiety and is completely wrapped by
fair and has mild PTSD so it altered her
appearance quite dramatically in order
to blend in at her new school this is
basically transforms from a fearless
character to a fearful one so in this
season she's kind of decided she's had
enough and wants barely holding me back
it was fun to play because suddenly I
was super confident and yeah it was fun
because I don't usually play characters
like that so it was a challenge so you
see - with a character like Kinsey which
I think you probably appreciate as well
as that like she is a complicated
character and that there's also this
dark
side of Kinsey that kind of comes out I
thought really in episode five with the
music box and when she's kind of yeah
you know making Eden a little humiliated
but it's to me justifiable in the
beginning but then as it goes on you see
Scott's like okay that's enough but she
keeps going for you playing Kinsey did
you justify this in your head or did you
believe it was like also over-the-top
like what was your thoughts on that no I
did I I thought Kim she did take it too
far but I think this you know if you're
taking out a very important emotion out
on your head then I think there are
consequences and that's yeah I found out
that there's a scientific reason for why
teenagers can behave badly there's like
a crucial part of the brain called the
frontal lobe that aren't fully connected
and it's basically the core of the brain
that says so this a good idea like what
are the consequences of this action so
that's why teenagers can get themselves
into trouble and I just I think yeah I
think the way throwing games use the
head key to explore the teenage stage is
really clever
you know Kim she's going through this
difficult phase anyway but and she was
kissing and controller and then she
takes that this whole emotion out of her
head it's kind of a recipe for disaster
and Sarah such a youthful emotion
especially for teenagers so yeah I I'd
say well someone asked me are there any
similarities or differences and I say
the difference is that I wouldn't have
done that to poor eating right that's
the other thing too is you look at this
like whirlwinds of a character Kenzi is
in that she's in this love triangle with
Scott and Gabe now she's she starts to
lean more towards Gabe and I feel like
as the season goes on and leaving out
the twist at the end about Gabe who
would you believe
where's Amelia think it's really better
for Kinsey good question I think Scott I
do as much as I love gay when I adore
Griffin I think I think Scott is better
for Kinsey because he's more realistic
you know he's not always saying yes and
you know you know digging Kingsley after
making I feel special you know Scott is
he tells the truth
he's a very truthful character and he's
very kind I think he helped Kinsey a lot
at the
when she first came to Madison he was
her only friend and he was really good
for yeah I think yeah I see that like
that Scott also was like just more
honest towards Kinsey and maybe Gabe's a
little more yes-man you know what's
interesting is about Kinsey I would say
from the audience perspective the most
talked about line is her suggestion of
dating both gaben Scott thank you he's
had what she's thinking here when she
says that well she likes both of them
she can't decide she has no sense the
office see she has no filter so it was a
fun scene to film yeah I could imagine
I'm guess you're saying to that like
this all kind of still goes back to the
fear monster being taken out in a sense
that we might see different results if
that didn't happen yeah exactly I think
I think the reason why she thinks it's
acceptable to ask them to date both of
them is because you have no said what
what the hell I like them both why not I
love that now
Emilio did you read the graphic novel of
lock and key before you started the show
yes I did my my brother's actually a
huge fan of the comic book so when I was
auditioning he gave me them all to read
and he sat me down and she gave me a
rundown on TV he picked my clothes for
the audition further down the line yeah
I know right
he said I mean he said yeah yeah you got
the part because I helped you because
yes he gave me he also gave me this
necklace a wing necklace because
obviously there's that iconic of
Killiney flying yeah
then further down the line of the
casting process I was given scripts one
to four to read and I loved how they
deducted it for TV and then when when I
write in Toronto I thought Morrissey
don't accept said one and two and I
talked in depth about Kinsey and we
decided that she had mild PTSD so I went
away and researched and tried to
incorporate a lot of the symptoms and my
role
so did you feel a certain type of
pressure jumping into a character that's
a beloved character from a comic like
did you feel that sense jumping into
this role I think that I love the comic
so much and I love I love Kinzie I think
I'm just so excited
I was just yet I couldn't wait to play
her and yeah be a lot I guess ya know
that that makes sense and knowing to
that it's like okay it's based off this
popular comic but also that you know
you're getting cast on a show that's on
a huge platform like Netflix and you're
no newbie with acting you've been acting
since age 8 but could you anticipate
that like it feels like with like your
Instagram let's say you had 40,000
followers on Instagram and then
overnight it's like 150,000 after a la
keeper man yeah how are you think it's
crazy how are you handling this spot
like though like is it is it
overwhelming or is exciting like what
are you feeling right now I mean I just
really wasn't expecting it so it's super
exciting and I just really I'd loved
hearing about how much people love the
story yeah and then people writing on my
things it's no excuse include their
season two like I'm dying to get a
season two yeah so I probably but people
have love love lucky key so I hope we
can continue it know I do too and I
think for all these followers coming to
your Instagram you actually have a great
Instagram and I think some of my
favorite stuff I've seen on there was
the actor of Scott doing the scare cam
with you I love Nicki Minaj super base
which is incredible so yeah how much fun
do you guys have together on say it
seems like you guys are such a
tight-knit group honestly it was the
best show I've ever done we every day we
would laugh it was just such an lovely
mix of people and everyone just had the
best time filming you wouldn't think we
were filming something that could be
dark sometimes because we were having so
much fun and yeah I got all really well
with every single actor and we meet up
all the time as well that's iconic like
Connor and acting are like brothers
mean we are like a family and then
Catrice obviously teases me every five
seconds
right yeah running off that what you
just said to that Connor and Jackson
like a family to you I thought one of
the biggest comments I give this show
was just from the beginning with the
casting and the chemistry you guys had
as siblings that I don't remember a show
that had such a convincing siblings trio
that I really believed you guys were
related and I want to know how did you
guys get to that like right off the bat
like what is that like as an actor like
you meet them and then it's like how do
you get that that you make sure in the
first scene you shoot that it's
believable you guys are like so close
you know what I think I think we got
lucky because the first day we all met
we just gelled and we got on so well I
met up with Connor I think a week before
we started rehearsals we went for coffee
and we and then we went for dinner and
then he came back this you know we just
react salute we got on like a house on
fire and yeah we just were like brother
and sister and then Jackson came along
and rehearsals and I have a little
brother so I kind of knew the same
things that Jackson's been to and
certainly Kai bonded over playing
fortnight and things like that and then
yeah just the three of us meant Derby as
well gabby is like a month to us you
know constantly checking that we're okay
and if we're warm enough and if we're
getting enough sleep and things like
that so yeah just I think we got really
lucky and we just all gel the new thing
on yeah it shows on screen for sure and
that's awesome to hear that you guys get
are so close you know off camera yeah
and uh what's what's interesting too is
that you've been acting since age of 8
like I mentioned before this isn't your
first rodeo and you were nominated for a
BAFTA 2019 for young performer for
Horrible Histories the movie now as an
actress growing up and it's a profession
that people are always constantly
checking themselves and feeling secure
about am I doing this right
how much confidence did that give you
getting nominated for a BAFTA I like did
that kind of give you a little more
oomph to like believe in yourself in a
sense I was not expecting it when yeah
when I found out I I had yeah I was only
completely shocked I'm super happy
because I was also nominated against two
of my close friends so it was kind of
like a reunion we all got to see each
other and it was lovely and yeah my
friend won and that and I thought she
deserved it
she's a brilliant young actress so it
was such a fun night and I couldn't
believe that I was nominated I felt so
lucky that's really cool that that
happened for you and uh as this actress
now it's coming up and you're this
rising star is there a specific idol of
an actress or an actor for you that you
look up to such a good question
well I hey when I was younger um I
watched room I watch some brie Larson in
in that and that kind of made me
it's a I said I want to do that I want I
want to do a role like that I want to
add be able to act like that and so I
really admire Meyers what she did in
that film I meant a lot to me
and I love I love Olivia Colman
I think she's brilliant I think she's so
natural and complain that's different
characters so I think she's our equal to
I mean you watch I'll start listing
something funny Timothy Timothy Valerie
is really good to know those are those
are great choices I definitely see a
little bit of all them in your acting
too so which is pretty cool so are you
saying that no I'm serious to what
actually really impressed me is
literally when I did my research for
this interview I had no idea that you
had a British accent and I was so
convinced by your America so do you keep
that accent on set or like you are you
Anatomy like how are you doing that um I
do I love acting in American so I just
switch switch off and when they say cut
I go back into British yeah I always
have I mean when I was younger I used to
roleplay my friend even with my brother
and I could only do it in American I
don't know why maybe I was American in
my past life or something but III I
think I think you know what I think it
is I think it's more natural to act for
me anyway in American because you know
we would say hello how are you and
mouth drop whereas you know you guys
would say hey how are you like your
mouth when we drop it's all kind of it's
easy it's mumble I guess but what was
your favorite scene to shoot so far in
the show um
the cave the cave my awesome to shoot
yeah yeah filming the caves and and just
quit all the underwater stuff that we
had to do was swimming that was if you
know it's kind of like The Goonies I
liked it a lot it became ya know that's
really good comparison actually that was
like the fun adventure episode to watch
- I'm sure that was yeah yeah I guess
that's a blast filming yeah oh yeah and
also um another I really liked filming -
the scene in the last episode when we
have breakfast and we decide that we're
going to stay that was actually Darby
and Jackson and Aaron's last scene of
season 1 so that was a really fun thing
to play because although it was like we
were ending season once where the
audience and for ourselves so I like
something that thing too because I'm
really close for yeah that was that show
- and that was yeah very powerful scene
and really kind of gets us in the head
of where we're going season 2 and yeah
and you know we get this big reveal that
gave you know is basically dodge and is
there any thoughts or ideas you yourself
can see this story going with Kinzie
maybe next season what would you think
might happen well so I did go into the
writers room in LA but they were so
secretive didn't tell me anything and
they kind of took me into the writers
room for about two seconds
and I didn't bring my glass which I
couldn't see what was up and on the
walls but I think I think the way season
1 ended is exciting for Kinzie because
there are a couple of storylines that
that could progress me to you - I think
Carlton who said that season 1 is about
the kids basically discovering that
they're the keepers of the key and then
season 2 is about figuring out what the
responsibility is so it would be really
fun I mean maybe Kings II might put her
back in her own
um Tyler Ferguson Maddox maybe now who
thank team yeah maybe though that I
think those would be cool storylines to
explore yeah for sure
now my last question before I let you go
Amelia is what he would Emilia want the
most mmm I have two can I be greedy
okay the head key I think is a fantastic
key and to be able to enter someone's
mind and psyche is really fascinating
but also super helpful you know to be
able to put things in your head and take
things out I mean I could have I could
have done with that when I was at school
I could put a whole physics textbook in
my head so it would have made revising
for exams easier and then I have a fear
of vomit so I definitely take that out
and then the anyway key the anyway key
is awesome
I was away from home for nine months
last year filming so I wouldn't use the
anyway key to pop home for cuddles with
my dog wow that Stan is beautiful
Amelia thank you so much for joining me
today is there anything else you want to
put let you go um well I did I did just
finish the film called coda which was
super fun to film was shot in
Massachusetts I belong sign language for
the role I had to learn how to fish they
sent me out at like 4:00 a.m. on a
trawler and I didn't I didn't come back
in till it was dark and I just not like
fish guts and things and I had some had
to sing a lot in it too so it was a
challenge but I loved it it was really
fun so hopefully that should be coming
out soon awesome so yeah everyone
listening make sure to check that out
when it comes out and obviously make
sure if you haven't watched locking key
on Netflix binge it it is great it's so
much fun yeah we want to season - yes of
course let's make that happen everyone
can help and of course watch familia
Jones is great performance as Kinsey
lock Emilia once again happy belated
birthday and thank you for joining me
thank you talking to you